on va faire maintenant le maître du
monde de la semaine qui sait pour vous -
pour moi pour moi j'ai un maître du
monde de la semaine
ouais pour ma le maître du monde la
semaine c'est le mec qui a laissé le
micro de jody google i o bouche ouverts
et on a entendu tout ce qui faisait tu
vois ce genre al islah c'est un trou du
cul et pour moi le maître du monde ces
deux mecs qui a laissé le micro ouvert
est ce que vous pensez il est viré 1 et
tout l'appui de chiens et ils font pas
comme les corses ma faim et dormi au mon
avis le cactus vous avez présenté ces
derniers jours qu'elle vous aviez un
maître du monde de la semaine a désigné
prix sur la wallonne avait fait un titre
et c'est vrai que ce type était c'est
énorme ça formidable parce que je pense
que c'est dans ces tout petits instants
de vérité qu'on voit qui est un homme
est au fond george bush on n'a pas
réussi à le coincer sur tous nos
manou et là tout d'un coup après on voit
quelque chose on verra ce que ça donnera
mais charles je vais mettre du coeur de
la semaine comme ça de but en blanc
ah oui si moi j'ai trouvé un truc
formidable fidel castro qui est arrivé à
parler dans cinq minutes
oui jérémie c'est fabuleux si vous avez
vu le type de corée du nord qu'on n'a
pas laissé passé ils ont fait une plus
corporelle ce extraordinaire c'est le
dictateur de la corée du nord vers un
maître du monde de la semaine vous veut
pas une maîtresse saab est une maîtresse
bien sûr oui il prend une maîtresse je
dis pas tous masculins et féminins 13
toi c'est mieux pour l'équipe
d'accord alors je prends ma femme prend
ta femme alors voilà on regarde ma femme
c'est bien oui pour un bon maître du
monde c'est mon fils à moi à oui ça
c'est vrai que c'était tranquille et à
mon avis la semaine prochaine ils vont
encore regagné 1,1 degré dictateur
crystal meth du monde de la semaine -
peut-être pas de semaine mais dans deux
semaines jeux olympiques j'aurais bien
voulu que jamais pour ascanio cran